for a joyous and just school they
shouldn't have to fight for a school
that will help
that child maintain their identities
that will celebrate them as their family
as a family unit and so that's why i
work so hard to make sure that families
know that they're welcome
that we love them that we're so excited
to share the school and that we
acknowledge their child
as their biggest sacrifice their biggest
joy and so to hand that over to us
we have to treat it children with care
superintendent dr jesus jarrah said
she's an example of the american dream
her two-based family immigrated to the
u.s from colombia
when she was just a child and during the
presentation you could just really see a
twinkle in her eye
when everyone talked about her and they
thanked her she mentioned she would love
to have a parade down las vegas
boulevard but right now
some properties along the strip have
agreed to put her picture up on display
after four o'clock this afternoon
reporting outside booker elementary
hector mejia
8 news now she certainly would deserve a
parade to be sure hector thank you very
much so
we shared the announcement of mr trube's
a big
reveal live this morning on good day las
vegas bianca holman shares a special
moment
a dramatic reveal on cbs this morning
led into uplifting news for the silver
state
and our city and the 2021 national
teacher of the year drum roll pleased
tony and anthony
juliana ortiz of las vegas
er ertube is a special education teacher
like all educators this year she worked
hard to ensure no child fell through the
cracks
first lady dr jill biden walked into
kermit booker elementary school library
surprising the teacher of the year with
flowers ertv says dr biden is one of her
heroes and it was a shock to meet her
and hear words of
gratitude from her students cbs this
morning anchor tony decouple asked
ertabay what teachers need
teaching is heart to work you know it's
a work of the heart and
it's about connecting and making
relationships i'm advocating for
students to have a joyous and just
education
this dedicated educator is known as miss
earth using a garden to give her
students hands-on experiences
and lessons that reflect their culture
for many of her students
english is a second language since erda
bay is bilingual she goes
beyond what is required bonding with her
spanish-speaking families on good day
las vegas she shared the impact of the
pandemic
this year has really just made us
realize how important it is
to maintain our connections to each
other this is a team
we absolutely have to work together with
families and partner with them
and the students and just keep
focused on what is truly important which
is our students being well
and safe and taken care of as the first
teacher of the year from nevada to be
recognized as the national teacher of
the year
erda bay will use this upcoming year
serving as an advocate for all teachers
bianca holman 8 news now